Speaker 1: But as I mentioned,
there's the opposite
side of the spectrum that appears to be far
too prevalent within the Republican Party.
And those, of course, are the individuals who say,
don't get vaccinated, don't trust the vaccines.
There's more of us than there are of them. And
of course, those are the talking points that
came out of Sarah Palin at the Turning
Point USA conference this past weekend.
In fact, Palin went as far as to say that
she'll get the vaccine over her dead body.
Which you may have wanted to choose your
words a little more carefully there,
because we've seen what this virus does.
800000 Americans dead saying over my dead body,
probably not the best choice of words there. So
let me read you what Palin had to say during her
little Q&A at the TPY USA conference. We were led
to believe that we wouldn't have to have the shot.
Well, then they changed their tune. And now those
of us who have had COVID, they're telling us that
even though we've had it and we have natural
immunity now that we still have to get a shot,
it will be over my dead body that I'll have
to get a shot. I will not do it. Again,
probably not a good choice of words there. And
of course, before I go into what else, she said,
natural immunity does not provide you the same
level of protection as the vaccines. The studies
have already shown that, yes, natural immunity can
provide you some protection from it. Absolutely.
But it doesn't give you as much protection as the
vaccines. So let's dispel with that talking point
right off the bat. But let's continue because
this is where things get weird. This is where
she differs from Trump. You know, Trump said, Oh,
you, you should get it. But if you don't want to,
you don't have to. Palin actively encouraged
people to straight up, not take it at all.
Here's what she says. There are more of us
than there are of them. You need to all look
around and realize as you stiffen your spine and
take those positions. And we know our rights,
especially when it comes to the government telling
us what we have to inject in our own bodies,
realize that those around you as you stiffen
your spine, their spines will stiffen to.
Is spine stiffening a symptom of COVID? Because
if it is, then I think she's spot on there.
But what she said, there's more of us than
there are of you, first of all, no, there's not.
There's actually more vaccinated people in this
country than there are unvaccinated people.
So right off the bat, you're wrong if
that is in fact what you're talking about.
Again, this is Sarah Palin, though, so
we really don't know exactly what she's
trying to say or what she might mean, because
that's how Sarah Palin operates. But if you're
like me, the biggest shock out
of what Sarah Palin said here.
Was the fact that she was even at the Turning
Point USA conference to begin with, right? At what
point did Sarah Palin become relevant again? Don't
they have enough right wing nut jobs out there to
fill that role now that they don't have to go tap
the well from the person who hasn't been relevant
since 2008? That's a little weird to me. Right?
Nobody even thinks about Sarah Palin anymore.
Kind of like Ann Colter, Ann Colter reemerges
twice a year with horrible talking point.
And then just disappears for like six months.
Sarah Palin's been irrelevant since 08, though.
So I don't know why. Turning Point said,
you know, who would be a good speaker here?
Sarah Palin. Maybe somebody got fired for that
decision. I don't know. But I got to tell you,
it's a little bit weird because she's not
exactly a newsmaker these days and certainly
not a major player at all in Republican
politics and probably won't continue to be one
if she's encouraging her base to do
things that could get them killed.
I'm Farron Cousins. You can follow me on Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram at fair and Balanced.
We'll be right back with more
of the David Pakman show.